so the year is ending in case you didn't
know that yeah we only got a couple
hours left and gallop did a poll on the
most admired men of 2014 so let's take a
look all right a lot of political people
here Barack Obama number one Pope
Francis number to Bill Clinton billy
graham george w bush ben Carson I
thought that one was kind of interesting
Stephen Hawking Bill Gates Bill O'Reilly
Benjamin and Yahoo and we were going to
put just leave it at 10 but then 11
snuck in Vladimir Putin so that one's
let's start with with Putin I kind of
think this is a little like there's
people that actually respect what a nut
bag he is like he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about anything we should press on on Fox
there they talk about how they like
Putin a lot I mean not you know what
just to quote took to contrast him with
Barack Obama who's such a big wussy but
Putin the strongman they admire that I
mean they're simple minded they
appreciate an authority figure who is
authoritative and that he gives them
that yeah it definitely matter what the
policies are appeals to all of our did
write about Putin right he's strong he's
a little bit crazy and he has his
philosophy I see I like I take just
takes yeah and he just takes he just
takes it right he took Robert Kraft
Super Bowl ring he took Crimea yeah and
I heard that he took some oligarchs
house on the on the outside of London
but he took Robert Kraft Super Bowl ring
he's that yeah how did you do that well
Robert Kraft was it was in Russia
visiting and Putin saw his ring is like
I like your ring he's like yeah this is
my super boring take a look at it it was
yeah I like it you just took it and
Robert crashes like uh can I have that
back yeah and one of the security guys
were like no no no this is your gift to
mr. Putin wow so Putin has a super bowl
yeah that is something yeah that is
something yeah so I agree it is the kind
of let's go back to list for just a
second there so Obama number one you
know look I certain people so Obama
number one Francis number to those of
you know those are the big the big shots
what do you like they're welcome Billy
Graham yeah it's like I mean uh he's
hanging on it's good for me he's he's
been apparently in the top ten off and
on for the past 75 years yeah and I'm
wondering like are these are they going
back to the same people every year
because nobody under 80
five is saying Billy Graham or even
knows who Billy Graham is but that he
keeps making on the list is admirable in
some ways I right so a lot of its just
name recognition obviously because
you're just picking in what do you think
of george w bush i know you're a big fan
of george w bush and all his policy it's
so this list is odd I mean this is gal I
mean this is the gallery look I get it
it's famous people right i mean you know
the guy who does some great work in your
local neighborhood he won't be on this
list I get it but how is George Bush
even relevant anymore he's been out of
office for eight years or six years like
what to admire about him at this is what
it's what it really is is a museum bhama
position oh no it's an open-ended
question where they don't give you a
list of possibilities they make you come
up with it yourself and the average
American it's not the most admired least
it's more like name somebody famous
besides Kim Kardashian cuz you know you
can't say her so it's like oh and a lot
of people probably still think George
Bush is president I mean they're not
they're right you know they're not
narrowing down the field that not only
of the people you can select but people
are asking that's really sad that is
said so to that point though what why is
it that we admire politicians after
being in the news biz for a year and a
half or two years now I have so little
regard for politicians never think
they're telling the truth all the stuff
that we all know but why do people still
so it's just the recognition I getting
it is a bowl like this but in general
why do people think the politicians I
something I don't think we I think we
attribute to politicians and to our
leaders the qualities that we wish they
had right because we want to believe
that they are leading us and that we
want to be optimistic about our future
and our present state so we attribute
these qualities to them that we wish all
leaders had and that's why in every
fictional account of anything whether
it's religion or it's a Hollywood movie
they have a possessed these unbelievable
human traits of strength and integrity
and all of that that in real life isn't
is rarely displayed right in real life
they're getting [ __ ] in bathrooms
and what else are they doing well I got
nuts that's something I could admire
wait a minute
you